essays latest comedy special has been
released by comedy dynamic past and
present imperfectly we have Tom Arnold
here yes thank you my friend you go back
with her don't you I do
that's damn damn sports I love Maria
days yes I said well we started the show
2001 we started with the differ light up
and I said please let's wait till
Michael gets out of jail it's worth it
oh he had some trouble but you know as
the guy says to throw myself first of
all I do he would be amazing on the show
and you know Michael Irvin is there's
just something about that guy he's
always willing to help other people
we're all imperfect and he's hilarious
and occasionally inappropriate and I
just just love the guy well he was at my
wedding
well he said my wedding to my daughter's
baby naming okay because we had it yeah
boards you probably didn't expect coming
out of my mouth here but my daughter's
born we had to have the ceremony on a
Saturday because sunday was NFL Sunday
game day morning so we had it on a
Saturday it was difficult to get a rabbi
on the Sabbath I found a rabbi on the
Sabbath well and the rabbi she says to
us at the end of my ceremony that
somebody gets to speak a special speaker
and I turned to Susie my wife and I'm
like this is only one if we could get
her and he gave the most passionate
speech about fatherhood and family and
what it means in this world it was
amazing yes amazing yeah he did he did
the same at our wedding and I'll tell
you what it came tide to lift the chairs
just loves the heat is embraces the you
know because Michael Irvin is not Jewish
I don't know
you know and just his speech today he
got into it and he covered a lot of
areas said to hear somewhat in front of
your whole it loss families say you know
Tom did to cocaine and it was well I'm
sure it was fun but I been there and now
it's all over
you know he covers a lot of ground in
your wedding speech well I'm which
wedding that was the third Maxine Waters
was there I will say that in a couple I
was married to a political consultant
for your third yeah 30 way yeah okay
yeah so he'll be it all of them you know
Michael so one of your wives is in the
news lately yes yes yes by you know it's
funny cuz like my status special came
out today and what we're shooting it
first year I said you know guys I'm
gonna to cover a lot of my life I talk
about my life on stage and I want to get
it up to the point where Here I am 59 am
a five year old at a two year old and
actually I've been together 10 years but
I'm so happy but I want to talk about
the early age too when I worked on the
Roseanne show and my ex-wife and I
wanted to have our old sports there I
want to do a chronology my whole life
and getting here and and I said you know
there's a rose and reboot come but I
said I think it's gonna be in the news
on Jude v but I have my special comes
nothing like no I don't think so I go no
I think it's gonna be big news and I can
make fun of the fact that I have a
little rinky-dink comedy special on this
stupid Network and she has a huge hit TV
should all make fun of myself they're
like do you think it that that was the
planet it's going swimmingly so far yeah
what do you think when is this whole
thing at down I you know I thought you
know I talked to kibble the whole ways
from day one I'm like oh boy this is
gonna go is he friendly with me he cares
about her but you know he's on ABC I do
I mean you know you you see things and
you're privy to things that you know I
know it's a trade wreck but when well
you know if you follow her social media
you can see jemelle Hill would not get
away with what she was doing right that
is correct for real and I was tweeting
what is I was hopefully - tweeted ABC
what is a Disney social media policy
about dot C's and like this is actively
this is a one-time thing that colleague
Valerie Jarrett a monkey this is going
on and on and on
okay so you know I I was trying to be as
helpful as possible you know I have kids
and communicating it they're concerned
there's a lot of people this country
whose parents have gone off the deep end
you know it's not just you know there's
been so little this involves of course
and people might think it was when
Thoreau said was oh my gosh she has the
opportunity to to stop and go oh my gosh
what if I got did to it and be an
example for all these people my own
family my own families are the safe
place to go oh my gosh what are we doing
let's take a step back what is true what
is not true because we have a president
that's just just perpetuating it going
I'm the real thing even Rosanna I have
to say this her good buddy Donald Trump
who we both known for 30 years I've been
to the Playboy Mansion with Donald Trump
and I wasn't the creepy guy he used to
come I like sports show all the time and
it's up but it would this wet down ed
she you know he called her with ratings
for number one
but with this went down instead of
having her back he went oh what about me
though why is it ABC apologized to me he
made it about him so he Billy bushed her
see so he dumped her so wit would so I
just felt like at some point she could
have gone whoa I got into this thing it
was fun at first it was kind of a bit
like a spy novel and now everybody's got
too far what it's really true let's take
a step back everybody she could have
been the best example for all these
people that believe all this nonsense
well I know that Kimmel tweeted out
about mental health yeah that's the
reason why I asked yeah it was yeah like
I think it's you know I talked to her
daughter last night Jenny Jenny padlet
it I said Jenny Pamela when she was 14
is she outsmarted be at her bob at her
dad I mean she was just and at 42 she
still it because I would have told her
yesterday
I had the planet the whole time I was
like get her phone get her phone in fact
I set up a picture of a phone they you
you tweet it too but it goes to a dimmer
server you know I had my vice guys come
up with this phone it goes to dimmer
server before it goes up and you add
like a Twitter intervention yeah yeah
yeah yeah because I though I would grab
her phone thing I you know with my
nephew who was a got it kicked out of
the army for a suicide tip and then I
saw his guts on social media I was
headed to Arizona to take his guts and
his dad warned him I was like I'm just
gonna take his friggin guns and they're
like oh my god that's the second better
and he ended up you know I've written
about it killing himself
I'm like take his guns take it in there
like first a bit but can't take your
vote I like take your phone but that
simplifies things and it's more
complicated than that and I heard from
Jenny pill and last night again and she
probably she is right you know you can't
just take these but you know you might
think it was like it's turn off the
Wi-Fi shut off the lights just get that
phone who is watching who speak you know
in charge over there but there are other
things there's billions of people whose
parents are like what is going on with
my I gotta do something and maybe it's
not as simple as take the phone but
there's but somebody needs to be talking
about it there is mental illness you
know III I've I have mental illness I
was with Roseanne she would she went to
the multiple personality thing we did it
as a family we spent a lot of time at
Johns Hopkins but this is a different
kind of mental illness and it's anxiety
but based and if you stay on that social
media and you state you know that's like
a crack for people with mental illness
who keep reading that conspiracy stuff
and you believe it you got to get off of
there for for a period of time and then
you got to get your wits and work with a
professional because there's a lot of
suicides in this country rich and people
because people just get hopeless and as
it gets too much and it gets so
dangerous maybe this is a great moment
for everybody to go well let's just take
a pause if we had leaders that will go
wait a minute this is everybody let's
take a beat instead of leaders ago what
about me it's rigged system it's crazy
it's dangerous people of color or
dangerous people of color after me
they're dealing get those sub [ __ ]
off the field that's what we have right
now and that's that's unacceptable let's
take a break
in 60 seconds with more with tomorrow
we'll talk a little bit with you okay
okay Tom Arnold here on the Rich Eisen
show back in the past and present
imperfectly it was taped on November
11th of last year right here in Los
Angeles and it's finally getting for
everybody to see their eyeballs on it
check it out right now with Tom Arnold
past and present imperfectly he go on
iTunes Amazon DirecTV 18t right here
Google Play other cable and satellite
companies and later on on Friday all
digital and physical audio retailers
will have the comic stylings of Tom
Arnold the latest from him you concerned
about your Giants level would be what
first of all you got a lot of best
stands for show love died of this
building right now a lot of goodbye my
concerned oh I'm thrilled I'm so excited
about the Giants this year last year as
you know Steve Tisch best man about what
best best man I've ever had last year I
felt like Giants management including
Steve Tisch the bear is disrespected by
quarterback Eli Manning and I let them
have it we all let them have it it
pulled Giants nation together we had a
great draft I am so excited about the
season this year and I very excited yes
a qualm barkley I just had nothing but
love for that kid for the last two years
and we've had him on the show and I just
he's got his head so screwed on directly
right I mean I just let's see this we
should have beaten Penn State like we
beat Ohio State last year but who's the
weak Iowa Hawkeyes okay see the shirt
here oh yeah that's what you know they
people made a big deal about this where
we wave it shows up well we just do that
that's I oh we don't need the publicity
right waving to the children yeah we
just do that ESPN brings the cameras or
makes people but that's what we do every
day of the week that was a rough loss
stage yeah was a rough loss rich it's
funny it's funny it was a terrible loss
we let up we but we but this how about
Ohio State forcing it how about
that deal anyway this kid but this kid
he's amazing and it's gonna be just a
hope I don't know what's gonna happen
but we are so excited you know what I
was driving behind the burials hotel I
saw a little mark can can walkie and
some kind of a walk that old people do
and his white sweat suit and and he
barked and you never ever used to ride a
little guy that used to ride a Columbia
yeah give me a little boy waves like you
know hey the Giants you know people that
are just fans you drive down the street
did they and they see it you know
they're just fans of your team it just
brings people together hopefully he
doesn't hear what I just said about it
that's the great thing about being a fan
man isn't it in life cuz life is tough
and there's all kinds of weird is going
on but when you're a sports fan and you
have that connection you know you walk
in through an airport and you know I'm a
Cubs fan and people know that about me
they go oh I have that thing in common
and it's just wonderful I agree with you
I you know and and then to just I guess
bring it all full circle was that there
is a lot of division and sometimes
people may not understand that there is
something in common
you both root for the same team you both
want something happy to come out of a
certain aspect of life and you don't
know that there's common ground and
sometimes maybe sports is that ability
not to get too hokey here to do that
sort of thing let me just say one more
thing if you're a true sports that'd you
know the teams and you know it let me
just say this is less I would say about
you cannot say that Chicago is an awful
you know cry bear in apocalyptic town if
your cub said you know that town is the
greatest city in America cuz you bid
there and you've been to Wrigley even if
you're a White Sox fan you know you know
you know it's a great town because
you've been there you've experienced it
there's no way yes there's a bunch of
crime but you know how great that city
is because you're a sports fan you know
the truth so that's why it's important
to be a sports fan and know what America
really is about right yeah we just came
back from Kansas City where there was a
great charity event that with that big
stick I doubt it
yeah the most amazing thing the you know
the hospital with kids first we not be
how awesome is that we we had a great
weekend there tom the kids were at the
bowling event and we got to meet them
and there were four members of the
Kansas City Chiefs that just took their
time off on a Saturday to hang out there
and the people of Kansas City reacting
to the whole weekend
we're buzzing about it I emailed with a
couple of a fellow big slick
participants which was taran killam oh
yeah yeah first time and he emails me
back he's like is it sticking with you
in the same way that it's talking with
me and part of that is the people of
Kansas City that at one point I looked
at Riggle and I'm like I think I have
shaken the hands of every single person
in Canton when we go to Hall of Fame
we've meet honestly you meet every
single person in Stark County on City
shows up for those guys this is the best
charity event
they have weekend week whatever I'll
tell you what I wish they take you to
the hospital when I would we walk by one
of the kids rooms are the father
we just said oh he doesn't want to see
but he's upset and I said what's going
on it he said well he has to get a
procedure to get a colostomy oh let me
talk to him because I went in there I
had a colostomy I had a procedure and so
we sit and talk I go yeah it's amazing
cuz said eventually it's kind of cool
because then you know that anyway if we
talk it out we had obtained pictures I
showed my scars we talked about the how
long it's gonna last and I was kind of
like you know you know you know it's
actually a good thing and I had kind of
hated giving it up because they be all
this time we making all these jokes and
and it was just this great experience
where I could share something it was I
thought was the worst experience of my
life and these kids are just gifts you
know just these wonderful things and
where the parents are going through
that's what these people do for these
kids it's not just like I'll go to a
charity I'm gonna you know show my face
it's like oh my god you're a part of
something amazing and you guys what you
guys did and it represents it represents
Children's Mercy represents the sound in
the same way as the Chiefs the same way
as exactly just genuinely it's you know
what I have got a double on Bret
Saberhagen but I was there
yes he was on my team so I didn't have
that sort of but that should be that's
well if you doubled you're gonna die I
did but isn't that what these guys do it
all the local actors and famous people
from Kansas City kicked her and all
these guys they did we love it where
they're from
did Paul Rudd they raise two million yes
and they but they do it here route to it
Riggle and they're doing stuff here
rounds going to games and the Chiefs
step up these this is what this truly
and I did this is America all the time
and they're these guys are wonderful and
they do right I'm at all what they do me
too
look man it was great thank you guys
[Laughter]
past and present imperfectly check it
out right now where everything is put on
digitally right now Amazon iTunes
DirecTV AT&T Google Play and other cable
and satellite companies just to name a
few good to see you thank you buddy
Tom Arnold here Rich Eisen show weekdays
at noon eastern on audience